So, da bin ich, Leute. Broggers, richtig. Da, wo wir das letzte Mal aufgehört haben, weil ich habe wirklich vor, das zu benutzen.
Fällt mir nur so gerade ein und ja.
Dafür muss es erst mal gescheit funktionieren und noch ein paar Sachen, die ich gerne hätte,
eingebaut werden.
Nämlich, dass man pro Feld mehrere Werte anzeigen lassen kann, die wechseln alle fünf Sekunden oder sowas. Muss man halt mal ein bisschen rumbasteln.
Für alle, die den ersten Stream verpasst haben, überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Weil so viel, so kompliziertes haben wir nicht gemacht und ich zeige es auch gleich noch.
Was für Feld? Wie Feld? Data Field.
Ein Garmin Data Field. Wir haben ein Garmin Data Field entwickelt, vor ein paar Streams,
was wiederum selbst andere Data Fields anzeigen kann. Was den riesen Vorteil hat, dass man beispielsweise auf einem
Ja, dass man zum Beispiel auch, genau, dass man zum Beispiel auf einem Garmin Fahrradcomputer
unter der Karte mehrere Werte anzeigen lassen kann, wo Garmin selbst plus maximal, glaube, zwei Stück unterstützt.
Xeno, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich mache mal kurz Package Update auf meiner VM.
Ja.
Übrigens, hier der, der Message Champ, den wir letztens gebaut haben in Go.
Mr. SNA Alive, nein, Mr. SN Alive, nicht SNA Alive. Stripes, POG Subscription, Leute, danke schön für die ganzen Hyper Subscriptions hier.
Hier dieses Tool, was wir entwickelt haben in Go. Ich habe das auf der Arbeit ausprobiert, funktioniert wunderbar.
Also, ich meine, ich habe noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten angepasst.
Zum Beispiel heißt es nicht mehr Message Champ, weil ich wollte es nicht, dass man das hier mit Stream in so eine Verbindung bringt.
Und wobei, das mache ich normalerweise nicht. Also, mein Zeug, meine Tools heißen immer irgendwas mit Champ. Das in dem Fall jetzt nicht.
Und
das habe ich noch gerne. Ein paar Kleinigkeiten habe ich nicht. Es ist, wie gesagt, Leute, es ist zu 99 Prozent das, was wir hier
gebaut haben im Stream.
Irgendwas Kleines habe ich, glaube ich, noch geändert, aber nix, nix der Rede, der Rede wert, ja.
So, jetzt machen wir das einfach mal kurz zu. Das dicht, das auch alles dicht, das auch. Achso, ne, was mache ich denn?
Keck. Wollte Package Updates machen.
Oh, ich brauche ein bisschen, bisschen zackigere Musik. Lass mal kurz hier. Das, das mit, das ist mir too, too relaxing hier.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Bisschen laut.
Okay, ja, so.
Hat noch wer gemeckert, weil nicht erlaubt? Was meinst du, was in Go zu programmieren, oder was?
Nö.
Hat keiner gemeckert. Das automatisch laufen lassen?
Ach, das meinst du? Nö, bis jetzt nicht, wir machen das einfach.
Wir machen das einfach, da kriegt kein Hardner nach, das
wird jetzt einfach gemacht.
Leute, ich war heute echt verwirrt.
Es, ich habe heute in Frankfurt an der Ampel gestanden und da fuhr an mir, mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt finde,
da fuhr an mir ein LKW vorbei, da stand nicht Apple, sondern Apfel drauf
und es hatte ein silbernes Logo und ich dachte für einen ganz kurzen Moment, das wäre jemand,
das wäre Apple bloß auf deutsch geschrieben von dem Logo her. Warte mal, Apfel-Mauer-Frankfurt?
Vielleicht findet man das, Apfel-Frankfurt-Logo? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, das war Umzüge oder sowas, nein, Apfel-Umzüge?
Apfel-Logistik oder sowas? Ja, hier!
Das ist ein LKW an mir vorbeigefahren, da stand nur das da drauf, so ein silberner Apfel und daneben stand Apfel. Da war ich erst mal kurz irritiert.
Hä?
Was fährt hier an mir vorbei? Von Farben her könnte es Apple sein, vom Logo her nicht wirklich,
vom Deutschen auch nicht, das hat mein Brain ungefähr schon mal zehn Sekunden geleckt, als das Logo an mir vorbeigefahren ist.
Ich glaube denen, dass das tatsächlich, ich meine, es ist nicht angebissen und nichts, aber ich sage mal, dass von der Farbgebung her,
hätte das durchaus
von Apple sein können.
Und Apple verklagt ja sowas auch ganz gerne.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn die nicht bald einen Rechtsstreit mit Apple haben oder nicht schon vielleicht sogar einen Rechtsstreit mit Apple hatten.
Apple hat ja auch ein paar verloren, das darf man ja auch nicht unterschlagen oder sowas.
Apple hat ja alles und jeden verklagt, die haben ja sogar mal irgendwie,
was war das, eine Schule oder sowas? Die haben ganz merkwürdig irgendwie Leute verklagt, die,
irgendein Restaurant oder sowas, ganz krass merkwürdig das Zeug, also die haben teilweise wild random Leute verklagt,
die irgendwas mit Apfel hatten und da haben die auch schon einige Sachen verloren, also Apple ist da schon mega, mega krass drauf.
Trimax hatte ein Problem bei der Mac.
Das Schlimme daran ist, ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob G-Bait oder nicht, ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass das wirklich so ist.
Wahrscheinlich stimmt es auch und du G-Baitest gar nicht, oder?
Wahrscheinlich war das wirklich so, ich traue es denen komplett zu, dass das so war, ich glaube das sofort.
Ich kann es mir so gut vorstellen.
Hoffentlich machen die mal nichts mit Keks oder so, dann habe ich gelitten, da geht es ja um das Logo an den Kragen,
auch wenn ich ohne Probleme beweisen kann.
Apple ver... Ernsthaft?
Ich kann, wie gesagt,
ich dachte erst, ich dachte erst, es ist G-Bait,
aber dann habe ich gleich gedacht, aber es könnte, es könnte gut sein. Ey ohne Scheiß, ich kann, ich kann es mir, also
das ist so ein Ding, prinzipiell würde man erstmal denken G-Bait, aber das nächste ist,
ich, ich, ich, ich traue es denen zu, ich traue es denen zu.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding, das könnte, das traue ich ohne Probleme Apple instant zu.
Das Fragezeichen gleich G-Bait, ja stimmt, das habe ich auch schon gemacht.
Das, das Titel, das G-Bait-Fragezeichen im Titel, ja das stimmt schon, aber keine Ahnung.
Ich könnte es mir einfach vorstellen, dass es stimmt.
Ansonsten
heute morgen wieder, ich muss ja einen Tee trinken, du willst,
mir läuft mir die Nase gerade
und
ein bisschen, ich habe warmen Tee, mal gucken, ob das was hilft, war kalt. Ey, heute morgen, Leute,
ich habe mal wieder festgestellt,
wie sehr mir, und das lag diesmal nicht an der Bahn,
wie sehr mir
die Bahn auf den Keks geht, aber es hat nichts mit der Bahn direkt zu tun, sondern eigentlich müsste ich eher sagen, wie sehr mir
so ultra low IQ-Talk von fremden Leuten in der Nähe,
denen man zuhören muss, weil sie halt in der Nähe sitzen, auf den Sack geht.
Das war so richtigster ultra low IQ-Talk. So, ich kann das, ich kann das gar nicht nachmachen.
Was haben, was haben die erzählt?
Irgendwie, du machst dir das Leben schwer.
Also das, das, so richtig, so richtig,
das, das, die haben sich auch schon so richtig dumm angehört, alle. Ich hab's ja wieder, der eine erzählt dann irgendwie so, ah,
und dann, und dann musst du wieder was ausfüllen, wo sie sich nix dabei gedacht haben.
Dabei habe ich das denen schon dreimal gesagt, dass das nix bringt,
und, und dann sagt die andere, ja, deswegen mache ich das gar nicht, und da kommt der andere wieder, ah, du machst dir das Leben schwer,
du musst das so machen, wie ich. Oh, wenn ich diesen dummen low IQ-Talk im Zug höre, da dreh ich durch bei.
Bei Unraid gibt es jetzt ein Vier- ernsthaft, wo denn? Moment mal, wirklich?
Der Vier-Champ ist ja noch halb, ist doch cool, aber
also, da muss ich ja erst recht bald mal
updaten.
Ich habe aber gerade keinen Bock, daran weiterzubasteln und auch keine Zeit, noch gar kein Gehirn, keine Gehirn-Kapazität frei,
was da dran zu machen.
Doch, ich habe ein neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer,
aber ich ziehe die eigentlich nicht so gerne auf. Ich ziehe die wirklich immer nur auf.
Gibt es neue? Ich glaube, es gibt gar keine neuen, oder? Es gab letztens von denen so eine World-Linux-Championship-Geschichte.
Ich, aber wie gesagt, ich ziehe meine neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer gar nicht so gerne auf. Ich ziehe die immer nur auf, wenn es, wenn es halt nicht anders geht.
Und dann muss ich auch ein bisschen Musik anmachen, weil ich so diese, diese Stille von neues Cancelling-Kopfhörern...
Kennt ihr die neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer-Stille? Die ist anders als normale Stille. Man merkt, dass die Stille durch
eigentlich Fake-Stille ist, im neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer. Man merkt das irgendwie. Ich kann das extrem schwer beschreiben,
aber Leute, die schon mal ein neues Cancelling-Kopfhörer aufhaben, wissen vielleicht, was ich meine.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine? Dass neues Cancelling-Stille
keine richtige Stille ist, sondern dass eine neues
Cancelling-Stille ist. Ja, ein bisschen druck ist das auch, aber das ergibt ja auch Sinn, weil es ja im Prinzip
auch Schall ist, bloß
uminvertet zu dem, was die Mikrofone aufnehmen.
Fühlt sich komisch an.
Ein Spanier hat das gepublished. Was ist das hier?
Ach hier, für den...
Ja, die Spanier haben bestimmt auch Fiats.
Ja, tatsächlich. Gibt es was Neues?
Lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Lasst uns mal kurz checken. Set Servers.
Ja, ich war auch schon im Audio-Studio und sowas. Das ist halt wirklich still. Ja, da hörst du auch dann
irgendwie jedes kleinste Geräusch, was du machst oder wenn du irgendwie
Geräusche im Ohr hast oder irgendwas vom Atmen und so. Hörst du da viel genauer, aber das ist nicht die typische
Noise-Canceling-Stille. Die Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörer-Stille ist anders als Stille in einem Tonstudio.
Show me Set Servers.
Okay. Ja, super. Es gibt kein Release-Datum mehr an den Challenges.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen pp-iger, weil
jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, wann wir... Hier, New. Hier, das ist New. Doch, tatsächlich.
Die sind neu. Die haben wir schon gemacht. Hacke Web-Server.
Hier, Pull a Rabbit from a Hat.
Disappearing Trick. Das haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Leider hat er... Ich glaube, das ist sogar ein Deutscher, der das betreibt hier.
Hallo? Kann mich irgendein Deutscher hören?
Gibt es den eigentlich noch? Hatte der nicht auch mal einen Twitter-Account?
Twitter. Der hat sogar... Der hat doch sogar das Wort vom Stream hier retweetet. Bitter, Alter.
Oder besser gesagt, X.
Something went wrong. Ach, ernsthaft? Hätte ich jetzt... Hätte ich gar nicht gemerkt? Ich... Also, ich dachte, das gehört so.
Ich dachte, das ist normal. Gehen wir halt wieder auf Nitter.
Wie ist da eigentlich die richtige Domain?
Liegt das an Darkreader? Keine Ahnung. Ist mir auch... Ist mir auch egal.
So, gucken wir uns das hier an.
4. Oktober? Nö.
New Scenarios. Ach, guck mal, der hat ja jede Menge hier am Start.
Ja, die hatten wir auch. Der hat ja jede Menge am Start.
Hat der... Kann das sein, dass das... Dass das einfach unterschiedliche...
Ach, guck mal, der hat auch mittlere... Ach, hier steht sogar New dran. Ich bin ja blöd. Guck mal da. New, New.
Ja, fünf Stück können wir machen.
Ok, muss ich mir aufschreiben, Chatge. Machen wir in einem der nächsten Streams. Habe ich richtig Bock drauf.
Fünf Mal Set Servers New.
Sogar sieben Stück? Wirklich?
Habe ich mich jetzt irgendwie vielleicht verguckt? Ne, fünf, oder?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Ach, wenn man sich anmeldet, gibt es nochmal zwei extra. Das ist nice.
Hast du Linux Mint nicht schon gemacht? Doch, doch. Aber meine To-Dos sind teilweise echt nicht so wirklich super aktuell.
Ich hoffe dann, wenn was drankommt, ich erinnere mich wieder.
Also hier kann ich mich dran erinnern. Das haben wir auf jeden Fall alles gemacht.
Ja, also Java, Enigma, Hacker Webster. Das kenne ich noch. Da kann ich mich noch irgendwie dran erinnern.
An das mit dem Java kann ich mich auch noch dunkel dran erinnern. Da musste man irgendwelche JAR-Files
entzippen oder sowas.
Ganz, ganz weird-champig. Ich weiß, ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern.
Aber die habe ich auf jeden Fall noch nicht gesehen bis heute. Wusste ich nicht, dass es die gibt.
Ja, dann gucken wir uns das mal im nächsten Stream an. Erstmal kurz in Hackermann-Stimmung bringen.
Bevor wir richtig anfangen, ich zeige euch mal, was wir das letzte Mal gebaut haben,
dass ihr euch das besser vorstellen könnt, um was es eigentlich geht.
Machen wir wohl schon das Studio Code auf. Machen wir noch einen extra Termin.
Was ist denn das Richtige?
Das ist das Richtige.
So, und wir sind jetzt in 5Head-CD-Repos-5Head.
Geil, in welchem Ordner habe ich denn das überhaupt? Nicht Open Editors. Wie ging das? Open? Konnte man nicht sagen Open in?
Open Containing Folder.
Ach, hier unten. Garmin. Garmin POG.
Nice, Max. Sehr guter Pfad. Ja, alles, alles klar.
Da wäre ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen, dass ich das abgelegt habe unter
Home. Okay, so viel klar. Downloads. Garmin POG. Projects. To. 5Head.
Obvious, dass das da liegt.
Komplett obvious.
Ah, yes. So, und wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Nee, einfach Debug drücken.
Wo ist mein Debug-Knopf?
Ja, hier, so. Und jetzt sollte ein Simulator aufgehen. Ey, Funst!
So halb.
So halb, Funstes.
Ich musste Run Without Debugging machen, dann ging's, gell? Ich glaube, das normale Run ging nicht.
Aha, aha.
Moment, ich habe doch gesagt Run Without Debugging. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das...
Das ist nicht C-Sharp.
Das ist das Garmin eigene C.
Okay, was habe ich vergessen? Was musste man vorher noch machen, dass der Scheiß wieder funktioniert?
Oh, fuck, man. Wortschauen.
Was mich verwirrt, ist, dass da unten... Ah, jetzt. Jetzt macht es was. Guck mal.
Offline.
Nee, das ist einfach nur Backlight. Oder war es einfach... War es doch Start Debugging?
Oh, man. Ich weiß nicht mal, wie es funktioniert hat, Alter.
Oh, shit. Was war das jetzt für ein Problem? Warum geht das jetzt wieder nicht?
Build successful. Ja, geil. Das ging doch so.
Ist mein Visual Studio Code kaputt?
Kann der Scheiß nicht einfach mal funktionieren, wenn man nichts gemacht hat seit dem letzten Mal und einfach nur noch mal startet?
Okay, war vielleicht das Thema das Problem, weil ich kein Data... Aber Debug Playback, da steht doch gar nichts.
Aber Six Fields, ja, da steht nichts.
Ich kann jetzt sagen, Data Fields, Layout, 4 oder so.
So, da sollte jetzt eigentlich was dastehen. Macht es aber nicht.
Richtig räudig, Alter.
Sag mal, ist das das Richtige, was ich hier aufhabe?
Ja, gell?
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall das Richtige.
Och, man, warum geht das jetzt nicht? Das ist doch...
Das ist doch genau das Gleiche vom letzten Mal, Mann.
Es gibt doch in... Es gibt doch keine Debug-Konsole?
Das startet einfach gar nicht. Muss ich... Muss ich vielleicht... Was habe ich denn das letzte Mal noch gemacht?
Musste man... Musste man vielleicht sagen...
Was war das? Start?
Irgendwie... Aha!
Man musste... Es hat alles funktioniert, da hatte bloß keine Daten zu malen.
Man muss... Man muss Fake-Daten einschalten, dann funktioniert's.
Ja, Pog.
Okay, dann schalten wir das jetzt nochmal um.
Ja, wobei, das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Data-Fields... Jetzt ist abgekackt.
Ich dreh durch, ey.
Jetzt... Jetzt aber.
Simulation, Activity-Data, starten.
Start.
Okay, nice. Ja, das sieht jetzt ein bisschen kacke aus. Data-Fields, Layout, keine Ahnung.
7B.
6A.
Ist es wieder kaputt?
Okay, so. Perfekt. Perfekt. Können wir nicht... Können wir nicht einfach sagen 4 vielleicht? Pass auf, gleich kackt es wieder ab.
Nee, so ist gut. Okay, wunderbar. Meine Güte, Alter.
Was startet schon wieder?
Okay, so. Ich habe ja gesagt, ich zeige euch mal kurz, was wir gemacht haben, bevor... Bevor wir anfangen.
Ich habe vor kurzem angefangen zu programmieren mit Ausbild.
Ja, mit Ausbild ist immer am besten.
Ausbild ist Pog.
Wird in normalen Embedded-Geräten, die auch aufwändige Screens und Graphing haben, auch proprietäre C-Version genommen. Ganz ehrlich,
ich habe diese Form von C und irgendwelchem grad noch nie gesehen in der Form. Also, die meisten
Embedded-Dinger, die ich kenne, ist es jetzt nicht. Da müssen wir den Patrick fragen, der kennt sich mit sowas besser aus. Die ich kenne, sind mit C oder C++.
Haben dann halt irgendeinen super special Compiler, wie beispielsweise die ESPs. Die haben ja diese komische
GCC Extensia
Sache, die dann auch nicht immer das allerneueste unterstützt. Warum das ein eigener C-Dialekt sein muss, weiß ich nicht. Aber ganz im Ernst,
ich finde die Sprache gar nicht so übel.
Also, jetzt mal, jetzt mal, jetzt mal.
No joke.
Das ist besser als Raw C für sowas, weil es halt schön angepasst ist an den ganzen Kram.
Und irgendwie auch ein bisschen angenehmer als C++.
Also, ich finde es gar nicht schlecht. Ich finde es, ich finde es okay.
Das einzig Dumme ist, dass es für die Sprache halt nichts Gescheites gibt. Ja, du hast zum Beispiel Autocomplete.
Theoretisch. Du denkst, du hast Autocomplete. Ja, zum Beispiel hast du hier einen, guck, einen Device-Kontext oder sowas. Weiß gar nicht, was die C ist.
SDC. Ich glaube, Device-Kontext oder sowas. Hier Display-Kontext oder irgendwie sowas.
Und da wird man jetzt denken, man macht da einen Punkt hintendran und dann kriegt man angezeigt von diesem Objekt, was es hat. Aber nein, nein, macht es nicht.
Das Autocomplete kann einfach nur alles.
Das guckt, guckt, das zeigt bei jedem Objekt nicht das etwa das an, was dazugehört, sondern einfach alle Symbole, die es, die importiert sind.
Also total unsinnig. Manchmal Value, Punkt, Bäm. Es kommt immer das gleiche Kram. Komplett unsinnig.
Ich kann euch aber mal das, ich kann euch aber mal zeigen, was der eigentliche Hintergrund ist, warum ich das bauen will. Und zwar schauen wir uns mal ein Image an.
Ja, hier. Wunderbar, wunderbar. Hier sieht man es.
Also, das ist von dem, also Garmin hat glaube ich drei Fahrradcomputer, die haben den, die haben einen Edge 540, also die aktuelle Linie, 540, 840 und 1040.
Und im Prinzip unterscheiden die sich hauptsächlich erstmal durch die Größe des Displays und dann bei dem kleinen, das hat glaube ich auch kein Touchscreen.
Ähm, aber ansonsten ist mehr oder weniger, mehr oder weniger recht ähnlich zwischen den Geräten.
Zumindest ein Ding, was mich persönlich nervt ist, wenn man in der Data-Ansicht, äh, wenn man in der Kartenansicht ist, also so sieht die normale Ansicht aus, kann man noch Zeug einblenden, wie man will, aber es gibt eine Kartenansicht.
Die Kartenansicht kann auch so ein Profil anzeigen, wie der Berg gerade ist, aber das ist nicht das, worauf ich raus will.
Garmin unterstützt in dieser Kartenansicht maximal zwei Werte hier unten und das finde ich persönlich ein bisschen wenig.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir bauen ein eigenes Data-Field, was wiederum kleinere Data-Fields anzeigt.
Also, stellt euch mal vor, man würde hier ein großes Data-Field anzeigen und zwar meins, dann hätte man jetzt schon drei Stück da drin stehen an Werten, anstatt nur zwei.
Natürlich, darf man da auch nicht unter den Tisch kehren, natürlich ist die Anzeige dann von drei Werten logischerweise kleiner als die Anzeige von zwei Werten, aber das ist nicht schlimm, weil erstens kann man den Header wegmachen, wenn man sich grob merkt, wo was angezeigt wird, ja, und zweitens ist das eh wirklich, also riesengroß, wenn man da drüber sitzt und drauf guckt, das muss gar nicht so groß sein.
Also, man könnte da locker drei Stück unterbringen nebeneinander, leider unterstützt das Garmin nicht und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir bauen einfach mal ein eigenes Data-Field, so, und ihr seht ja, das funktioniert im Prinzip schon.
Was ich jetzt noch mal machen will, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das wäre ein richtig nice Feature, also es gibt schon ein paar ähnliche Sachen, es gibt zum Beispiel von irgendeinem holländischen, niederländischen Entwickler, zumindest hört sich das vom Namen her so an, ein Plugin, das kann bis zu sechs Sachen anzeigen.
Das habe ich auch mal ausprobiert, das ist sehr klein und hat ein paar Sachen, die mir nicht gefallen, ich kann euch das mal kurz zeigen, Connect IQ Store, Edge 840, was hast du denn, ich habe kein E-Bike, nein, mach mal Ausrufezeichen, ja, Fahrrad, vielleicht ist es auch Ausrufezeichen Bike und wenn das nicht geht, dann ist da ein Nightbot wieder am Bett gesleepen.
Ach, man muss es klein schreiben, Cringe Case Sensitive, ja, das ist das Fahrrad hier, korrekt, das hier, exzellent, jetzt geht beides und Fahrrad noch in klein.
Also es gibt eine App, die hat mich dazu inspiriert, sowas zu bauen, irgendwas, Erik hieß der glaube ich, ne, die haben die das rausgenommen oder was? Mal Highest Rated, ist der nicht Erik? Ach, Erik mit K, ja, guck mal, das ist so ein ähnliches Plugin, was ich ausprobiert habe, was ich von der Idee her mega nice fand, guck, der hat sowas ähnliches gebaut wie ich, der hat quasi aus einem Datafield, hier, das ist also 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 30, 31, 32, 31, 32, 33, 34, 34, 35, 36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 40, 41, 41, 41, 41, 41, 41, 41, 41, 41
Hat er, hat er im Prinzip 6 gemacht, für Garmin ist das 1, aber er zeichnet halt selbst 6, paar Sachen gefallen mir da dran nicht so richtig gut, ähm, das ist einmal die Anzeige hier von, von Heartbeat und so, den muss ich mir was überlegen, die, die, weiß ich nicht, find ich nicht so, nicht so nice
Also das, das hier sind die Heart, die, die, äh, Herzschlagzonen, grün, also Garmin hat grau, wobei, wir haben es doch hier auch schon drinnen, ja, Herzschlagzonen, genau, hier, grau, blau, grün, orange, rot, hat er hier auch drin, wahrscheinlich kann man hier noch Power und so einstellen, zumindest, was ich halt viel cooler finden würde, anstatt 6, achso, die Header kann man auch ausblenden, was ich halt viel cooler finden würde, anstatt 6 Anzeigen, die wirklich ziemlich klein sind
Habe ich überlegt, wir machen 3, wir machen 3, aber wir unterstützen noch, dass man das abwechseln kann, weil, zum Beispiel, überlegt mal, hier oben zeigt es jetzt die aktuelle Uhrzeit, geht mal davon, oder stellt euch mal vor, das wäre nicht die aktuelle Uhrzeit, sondern stellt euch mal vor, das wäre, machen wir mal hier sowas, ja
Stellt euch mal vor, das wäre der aktuelle Timer, seitdem man losgefahren ist, und jetzt würde das, äh, habe ich irgendwas vergessen, muss ich das stoppen, stoppen, Bild, Bild, jetzt Run, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, in welcher Reihenfolge das passieren musste, gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert
Ja, jetzt geht's, so, jetzt stellt euch mal vor, das hier wäre der Timer, seitdem man angefangen hat, zu radeln oder zu rennen, wobei man das beim Rennen eher nicht dabei hat, und jetzt würde das beispielsweise so im 3-Sekunden-Rhythmus anzeigen, Timer, sein, äh, sein Start und als nächstes, ähm, Ankunfts-Prediction zum Ziel, dass du quasi in einem Feld eigentlich 2 anzeigen lassen kannst
Per Swipe, ehrlich gesagt, finde ich Sachen, die man touchen muss, wenn man die Hände am Lenker hat, nicht so gut, was ich extrem nice finden würde, was aber leider nicht funktioniert, ich habe ja eine elektronische Schaltung am Fahrrad, das wäre extrem poggers, wenn man das einbauen könnte, aber das geht nicht
Das sieht, äh, folgendermaßen aus, äh, guckt euch das mal an, davon ist jetzt natürlich wieder kein gescheites Bild da, aber, die, ja man müsste das mal innen sehen, warum sieht man das nicht innen? Warum ist das Bild so dumm?
Also innen haben die nämlich einen Knopf, die, die Brems, die Bremshebel, äh, man sieht, ne, nicht, nicht innen, oben, was erzähl ich denn, oben, ja, hier sieht man es, guck, die haben oben, die haben oben einen Knopf, da kann man draufdrücken, so, und es wäre extrem geil, wenn man den Knopf, es wäre extrem geil, wenn man diesen Knopf mappen könnte, auf hier
Und was, leider geht das nicht, also es scheint nicht supported zu sein, man kann das Ding zwar pairen mit dem Garmin, und man, man kann, man kann beispielsweise mit dem, mit dem Knopf dann, äh, vor- und zurückblättern auf dem Garmin, das funktioniert, weil das eben die Garmin-Firmware selbst implementiert, aber man kann leider in der API das Ganze nicht ansprechen, zumindest, ich habe danach gesucht
Und, und man findet zwar paar Beispiele, aber man findet nicht, wie das, guck hier, es gibt ein paar Leute, die das gefragt haben, aber es scheint nicht zu funktionieren
Das wäre halt cool, wenn man das mit dem Knopf, wie gesagt, das funktioniert nicht
Was ist das, was hat er hier gepostet, die iHack getappt, was ist das, gleich mal nach, nach, die iHack, Minecraft, nice, so
Die GAX, also, mein Fahrrad hat so ein GAX-Set, und das hat die Knöpfe, vielleicht nicht alle, aber meins hat Knöpfe
So, zumindest ist der Plan, dass das hier alle paar Sekunden umschaltet, ich meine, wir können es auch, wir können es auch mal mit Touch probieren, ja, das können, wir können, okay, dann probieren, ich schreibe mir das mal auf, das probieren wir auch mal, wir machen es mal mit Touch
Wobei mit Touch, ganz ehrlich, irgendwie ist, irgendwie ist doof mit Touch, weil mit Touch könnte man, könnte man einfach eine zweite, eine zweite Seite einbauen, wo eine Karte drauf ist und dann ab und zu mal umschalten zwischen den zwei Seiten mit der Karte und dann hat man auch unterschiedliche Werte
Aber wir können das, wir können das mal ausprobieren, ja, doch, doch, das Gerät hat auch Knöpfe an der Seite, aber die sind eigentlich schon vorbelegt, also es bleibt im Prinzip nur Touch oder irgendwas custommäßig, am liebsten hätte ich ja ohne, dass man touchen muss, weil ganz ehrlich, man hat, ich glaube, das Ding hat keinerlei Voice Control
Ich glaube, die App kann so ein paar Befehle sagen, die, die iOS App kann, glaube ich, ein paar Sprachbefehle, bin ich mir aber unschlüssig, ob das, ob das jetzt wirklich, nicht, dass ich Mist erzähle, aber das Gerät selbst hat keine Sprachsteuerung, ja, aber am besten, ganz ehrlich, Leute, ich, ich mache da auch am liebsten so wenig wie möglich, also ich mache, ich mache ehrlich gesagt während der Fahrt damit nur, gucke ich mir nur drei verschiedene Sachen an
Das erste ist meine Haupt, meine Main-Übersicht und das ist eben hier die ganzen Sensoren, dann schalte ich oftmals in die Navigationsübersicht und manchmal schalte ich noch in die, in die, wenn es den Berg hoch geht, schalte ich in die Bergübersicht, so wie der Anstieg ist, aber das kann man auch hier einplätten lassen
Also, deswegen, ich werde jetzt erstmal gucken, wie man, wie man das macht, dass man das automatisch umschalten kann und wobei erstmal, ne Leute, erstmal gucken wir, wie das mit dem Touch geht
Hehehe, genau, das, 5Head, 5Head-Idee
Okay, dann, dann probieren wir das doch mal mit Touch, wie macht man das mit Touch? Garmin SDK, Apidogs, Touch, Methods, Touch, IsTouchScreen, das heißt wahrscheinlich Touch, sondern Input, Input Buttons, was haben wir denn hier?
Physical Buttons supported on the device, okay, das sind, das sind die Buttons, die da dran sind, das ist schonmal Intent, was haben wir hier?
Ne, das brauchen wir nicht, Stats, äh, Batterie und sowas, Solar Intensity, Total Memory, das brauchen wir nicht, ist das Android? Nein, ist es nicht, auch wenn es Intent heißt, aber das wird nur öfters verwendet, es ist kein Android drunter
Background Events, ne, so funktioniert das schonmal nicht, okay, dann müssen wir mal googlen, Garmin SDK, GitHub, wir hatten doch so einen Typ auf GitHub, der mega viel nice, das da? Ja, das war der Typ hier, ne, Max, das ist doch das, was du gefunden hast, der hat total viel nice Beispiele, ne, ist er das? Ne, oder?
Shop, ne, das ist er nicht, GitHub, das da? Klick, ja, Klick können wir auch mal suchen, hier, der hat ganz viele Beispiele drin gehabt, wie man das macht, genau, oh, guck mal, man kann Web Requests, oh, das muss ich ausprobieren, Web Requests, oh, das wäre ja extrem nice, da kann ich mit meinem Garmin übers Handy Web Requests triggern,
weil das Ding hat selbst, das Ding hat selbst ja kein, kein GPS, kein 3G oder LTE oder sowas drin oder 5G, aber Web Requests übers Handy durch Tunnel wäre natürlich, Fahrrad, ohne Scheiß, das ist das erste, woran ich auch gedacht hab, da kannst du dann mit irgendeinem Knopfdruck oder mit irgendeinem Touch auf dem Garmin irgendwas auslösen, so, ich weiß noch nicht was, aber es wäre cool, wenn es funktioniert,
User Profile, ich guck mal hier nach Input, Sensor, Selectable, Selectable klingt doch schon mal nicht verkehrt, oder? Ah, mhm, mhm, alles klar, Google Translate, 3 Boxes, each of which can be checked, ok, das klingt schon mal nach irgendwas mit Input,
Beim Heim kommen Garage auf, meine Garage ist tatsächlich, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, aber, auch weil als Home Automation Fan, meine Garage ist nicht automatisiert, Button View, ne, das können wir wieder nicht, das können wir wieder nicht verwenden, aber man kann garantiert, Input, hier, Input, Source, hat er eine Readme? Ne, Source, Input, App, hier ist nichts drin, Input,
Ja, das ist Input von den Buttons, ich will ja keinen Button Input, ich will ja einen, On Touch, On Tap, ah, ja, On Tap, das wollen wir haben, View, ok, wie macht man das jetzt?
Set Behaviors to, oh, Alter, was, Update, Draw Text, ja, Draw Text, schön, Function Initialize, äh, äh, äh, und wo subscribed er irgendwie jetzt zu Touch Events? Verstehe ich nicht so ganz, hä, woher bekommt er die Events jetzt? Und warum ist hier eine Function außerhalb von der Klasse?
Das verstehe ich nicht so ganz, ah, Get Initial, ok, ah, muss man das hier so, muss man das hier so aufrufen, Input View und danach gibt es was, ein Input Delegate, aha, oh, shit, Alter, das kapiert doch wieder keiner, wie das funktioniert, Alter, Behavior Delegate Initialized, Button Pressed, what?
Wir haben doch hier eben nach Input gesucht, oder? Input, Input Buttons, ja, nice, gib nicht so viele, ja, Moment, das ist Device Settings, das bringt uns, das bringt uns ja nicht, Behavior Delegate, ok, Behavior Delegate Handles Behavior Input, alles klar, obviously, Chat, oder?
Ich glaube, jetzt ist alles klar.
Differs from Input Delegate, in that it acts upon device independently, what the hell, was zum, no, they don't wearable, wearable products, Input Events are not supported for data fields, ja, wir haben ja kein Wearable, wir haben, Moment, und dann gibt es noch ein Input Delegate.
Und was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen einem Behavior Delegate und einem Input Delegate? Ok, es differt, in that it acts upon device independent behavior, das ist das Next Page, instead of device specific button, ah, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Hiermit musst du wirklich checken, bist du auf ner Uhr, bist du auf nem Edge, da kriegst du dann sowas wie Edge Button 5, und hier kriegst du abstrakt eher, es wurde Next Page gepresst, oder Previous Page gepresst, egal wie der Button am Gerät wirklich heißt.
Ok, macht Sinn, das zu abstrahieren, ja, macht Sinn, die große Preisfrage ist jetzt nur, wie funzt das, wir kopieren einfach mal, wie hat er das hier genannt, einfach nur Input Delegate, ach Moment, hier ist es jetzt ein Input Delegate, und es ist ein Input Delegate, der Extended Behavior Delegate.
Ihr macht mich fertig, Alter, mit der Benamung, so, das heißt jetzt, anders, das heißt jetzt ganz einfach, New File, Tag Delegate, Punkt MC, so, perfekt.
Ok, schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert, und nun haben die was gemacht, Get Initial View, und dort hat er jetzt noch New Behavior Delegate, oder so, hintendran gehängt, Bild, geht bestimmt nicht, bildet nicht, nein, natürlich bildet es nicht, Error.
Excellent, da habe ich bestimmt irgendwas vergessen zu importen, bestimmt das alles importen, sonst geht es nicht, warum das Beispiel da nicht funktioniert, man weiß es nicht, nein.
Cannot Resolve Superclass Name Behavior Delegate, top, GG Eats, das ist ja toll, ach Moment, ne, moin, fuck man, und jetzt, aber angeblich gibt es das doch, ich muss sagen, das ist teilweise schon sehr weird Champ, und man versteht oftmals nicht, was das Problem ist.
Ok, ich, wisst ihr was ich mache, ich copy paste jetzt einfach mal das komplette von dem Typ hier, und gucke, ob es dann bildet, nein, dann bildet es komplett gar nicht mehr.
Ich bin ja auch ein Fan von Minimal Examples, so, was mache ich falsch, Cannot Resolve Superclass Name Behavior Delegate, ich benutze, benutze das offizielle Example von Garmin, und das funktioniert nicht, brauche ich dafür vielleicht irgendeine Permission.
Permission, Permission, irgendwas wie Input oder sowas, End Background, Data Feed Alert, Positioning, nicht wirklich, tja, mal googeln, aber ich fürchte bei dem Garmin Zeug wird man halt nicht viel finden, da findet man halt gar nichts zu.
Was hat eigentlich jemand vorhin im Chat hier gepostet, irgendjemand hat doch einen Link gepostet, zu, zu irgendeinem Garmin, was ist das denn, ich finde es nicht.
Irgendjemand hat doch eben vorhin einen Link gepostet und hat gemeint, ja das da, Monkey C Garmin, oh man kann da, Moment, es gibt ein, es gibt ein JetBrains Plugin, wait a minute, muss ich mich da nicht mit Visual Studio Code rumschlagen?
Ah, Hans Dampf, aber von 2018, ist vielleicht alles ein bisschen, sieht man Last Updated, Chat-Gear, sieht man die irgendwie Last Updated, von dem Source Code, oh, es ist Archived, ne die wollen sogar, dass man das Visual Studio Code Plugin benutzt.
Okay, aber warum, warum geht das nicht, also was, was, was stört ihn denn jetzt da dran? Ich, muss, muss das vielleicht hier wirklich, muss das hier vielleicht heißen, wie die, shit, shit man, wo ist das Problem?
Ey, wenn das Official Garmin-Example noch nicht mal funktioniert, ja? Maybe Compile Flag, ja, schön, aber was? Wir können noch mal schauen, hier wir gucken mal im Manifest von dem, von dem Kerl hier.
Monkey Jungle, Read Me, ne Moment, nicht Selectable, falsch, nicht Selectable, Input, Resources, hier Punkt Project, nix, Manifest XML, Edge, oh, hat er, hat er, die alten Edge-Computer drinstehen, ansonsten nix, ansonsten nix, ne.
Meine Güte, was ist das denn da für ein Müll? Ist das, ist das die große Preisfrage? Ist das erst, seitdem ich's included hab, oder vorher schon? Lassen wir das hier mal weg, Build, ne, Cannot Resolve Superclass, ja, dann kann ich ihm auch nicht helfen, wenn auch nicht mal das offizielle Exampel von Garmin funktioniert.
Aber ziemlicher, ziemlicher Müll, dass das nicht geht. Finden tut das, Function, ja, finden tut das, wenn ich das alles mal weglasse hier, Moment, jetzt ist, der findet das immer.
Okay, Chat, ich brauch Hivemind-Intelligenz, was könnte das sein, dass das nicht funktioniert? Das, die Exampel sind auf jeden Fall schon mal kacke. Wir können noch mal den Input-Delegate probieren, ob der funktioniert. Wenn man den hier nimmt, der funzt noch weniger. Warum funzt der jetzt nicht?
Was? Sag mal, wer hat denn diese, Garmin, wer hat denn diese Beispiele erstellt? Wollt ihr mich komplett rollen, oder was? Wer hat denn diese Beispiele erstellt, man? Build successful? Moment, da steht Watch UI. Guck mal, da steht Watch UI davor, in dem anderen stand nichts davor.
Wir probieren das jetzt auch mal so aus. Ne, Moment, geht jetzt, oder? Das ging jetzt, das ging jetzt, man muss Watch UI. davor schreiben. Jetzt ist hier das Problem mit Key Event, Get Key, was auch immer. Ja, nice, nice, okay, es bildet.
Alles klar, alright. Geiles, geiles Beispiel, ne? Das haben die im Leben nicht selbst ausprobiert. Successfully built. So, jetzt brauchen wir natürlich hier noch was Gescheites, brauchen wir OnTap, brauchen wir Function. Also, OnBack, OnMenu, OnPreviousPick, OnTap, Tap, OnTap.
Moment, das hab ich doch hier gesehen, dass es OnTap gibt. Tap, Sauce, ja. Ich hab da echt so meine Zweifel, ob das funktioniert, wenn es noch nicht mal in den offiziellen Garmin-Docs drin steht, dass es das gibt.
Ich bin da, OnFlick, ach, hier gibt es On, ah, Moment, Moment, Moment, BehaviorDelegate ist eine Ableitung von InputDelegate, das heißt, es hat das auch zusätzlich noch. Okay, also können wir sowas hier machen, Function, OnTap und jetzt sagen wir einfach nur Klick.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert, Leute. Chat, gemeint ihr, moin, hat es jetzt einen Fehler gehabt? Ah, SetAction, ja, Print, PrintLine. Meint ihr, es geht jetzt? Okay, Restart. Meint ihr, es tut jetzt? Ich bin skeptisch. So, DebugKonsole. Hä? Guck mal, es geht. Ich klicke drauf und es tappt.
Easy. So, jetzt muss ich nur noch rauskriegen, was in diesem Event alles so drin steht. EVT, ja, Autocomplete funzt ja nicht so richtig. Wir bekommen ein, nee, ein, ein, ein, ein, Tap, wo ist das? OnTap? Nee, OnTap? Hä? InputDelegate, On, what? Ach, OnTap.
Es ist ja keine Taste. Was ist das für eine Programmiersprache? Das ist MonkeySee, weil Garmin sich gedacht hat, das ist eine tolle Idee, da eine eigene Sprache für zu verwenden. Guck mal, Koordinaten, ja, genau das brauche ich. GetCoordinates, Koordinates, GetTheTypeOfTheClickEvent.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns das mal an. Okay, GetCoordinates und wir wollen GetTheType. So, Bild, Error. Hä? Wie jetzt? S, Watch, UI, Klick, Type. Ich habe legit absolut keinen Plastenschimmer, was ich hier treibe.
Geht das so? Nein, Error. Was? Klick, Type, PassedAsParameter1. What? Also, das ist echt weird champ, die Sprache. Ich verstehe oftmals gar nicht, was das mir sagen möchte mit irgendwelchen. Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, ob die Koordinaten stimmen, die da rauskommen jetzt.
Okay, Bild, Successful, Restart, Debug-Konsole. Also, wir sollten jetzt Koordinaten bekommen und dann müssen wir gucken, in welchem Feld die, ja, wir bekommen Koordinaten. Okay, und jetzt müssen wir quasi die, oh, das ist ja abfuck jetzt.
Jetzt muss ich die Koordinaten, das muss ich anders bauen. Jetzt muss ich die Koordinaten berechnen, dass ich weiß, in welchem Feld ich bin. Also, muss ich jetzt, das Problem ist, ich kann dafür nichts benutzen, was schon da ist, weil ich mal die Felder hier selber. Dementsprechend, ich könnte mir das eigentlich ausrechnen. Das werde ich heute aber nicht machen.
Da muss ich mir erstmal Gedanken machen. Das heißt, ich müsste mir quasi merken, wo die, wo meine Felder anfangen, oben links quasi, ne, oben links, Breite, dass ich jetzt, dass ich dann checken könnte, okay, ich hab jetzt in dieses, ich hab jetzt hier in das Datumsfeld geklickt und ich hab jetzt in das geklickt. Gibt es keine Buttons oder Schaltflächen, die erkennen können, wenn man draufklickt?
Also, ich hab bis jetzt nichts gefunden, ja. Also, es gibt, es gibt ja wohl sowas wie Button. Ja, Button, gibt's, gibt's sowas, ja, hab ich schon, hab ich schon gefunden. Aber, das, das kann ich anscheinend, das kann ich anscheinend dann nicht irgendwie hier in so nem Custom-Data-Feld reintrauen. Und, ich muss ja alles selber malen.
Weil, sonst, sonst müsste ich nen Layout benutzen, von Garmin, was schon da ist. Ich, ich glaube nicht, dass wir das mit der, mit der Variante machen können. Also, vielleicht, wenn man richtig Plan davon hat. Hab, also, ich hab nix, ich hab nix der, dergleichen hier gefunden, ja. Also, man kann den Button, aber, moment, hat so nen Button überhaupt nen Click-Event? Ne. Oder?
Das erbt von Selectable. Aber, guck mal hier. State Selected? Doch. Doch, doch, doch, das hat sowas. Wollen wir mal probieren nen Button zu malen? Wir, wir probieren mal nen Button zu malen. Wenn ich hier mal ansatzweise checken würde, wie man das, wie man das macht. Ja, okay. Probieren wir mal nen Button zu malen.
Das artet, das artet aber komplett aus jetzt, glaube ich. Machen wir mal nen Button. Button. Draw. Okay, okay. Ah. Das ist was komplett Neues. Aber, so funktioniert. Der, der Typ hat doch hier bestimmt, der hat doch hier Selectables, Selectables, hat der doch irgendwo hier mal nen Beispiel gehabt. Hier, Selectable, Source, Button.
Behavior Delegate. Schauen wir doch. Selectable App. Checkbox. Ja. Ja, Moment. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Button View. Ne, das bringt mir jetzt nix. Das, ich find das echt schwierig hier, hier durch zu klicken. Also, Checkbox View lädt er, so.
Okay, das ist der, das ist das eigentliche, was er anzeigt. Boah, das ist echt schwierig, da durch zu blicken. Ja, genau. Ich kann das ja. Das ist das Ding. Deswegen wird das nicht funktionieren. Die setzen das immer als Layout. Das will ich ja gar nicht.
Garmin Examples. Sources hier. Button. Selectable. Moment. Was ist das? GitHub Garmin. Hier vielleicht ein Exempel davon? Datafields Button. Garmin SDK Button Exempel. Input Handling. Button? New Button Initialize.
Fuck, Mann, Alter. New Watch. Man muss auf jeden Fall irgendwas mit New machen. Hier muss man das nicht machen. Hier vielleicht User Profil. Okay, mal gucken, ob, Moment, was kriegt man hier als Constructor? Was ist das?
Man weiß es nicht. Man kriegt auch keine Hilfe. Nice, Bock. Bild. Moment. Das hat keinen Fehler gegeben? Ha, da bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt. TS, TS, Button, Draw. Und jetzt auf den DC. Das klappt doch im Leben nicht, dass da jetzt ein Button rauskommt.
Okay. Okay. Kommt jetzt kein Button. Das klappt garantiert nicht. Er zeigt schon mal gar nichts an. Oh, gecrashed. Expected Method. Given Class Definition. Doch, doch, doch, New.
Ey, das ist ja abartig. Eine Error. Initialize. Okay. With Wrong Arguments. Ja, das ist schön. Das ist gut. Aber mit was für Arguments muss ich es denn callen? Weiß man nicht. Wird nicht angezeigt. Pogu. Nice. Okay. Watch UI Button. Initialize.
What? Was? Boah. Noch im Forum hatten die doch eben grad irgendein Beispiel. Guck mal hier. Ach du Scheiße, man. Okay. Dann, das lassen wir mal weg. Was ist das hier eigentlich für ein abartiges Konstrukt, was ich hier sehe?
Was ist das? Ist das ein Struct oder? Okay, es bildet. Build Successfully. Nice. Anonym ist wahrscheinlich. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ja, das ist kein Rabbit MQ, das ist ein Active MQ Tool, aber ja, das hat funktioniert. Sollte das jetzt nicht starten? Okay, Stop. Oder ist das grad schon wieder gecrashed?
Class Usage is not allowed for the current app type. Okay. Zaut. Bezaut, bitteschön, auch noch. Bezaut. Leute, ich glaube nicht, dass das. Watch UI Example. Wait a minute, man kann das in irgendeinem XML definieren? Es wird ja immer abgedrehter.
Ja, also das funktioniert ja bei mir nicht, weil ihr mir dann sagt, Class Usage is not allowed for the current app type. Das geht nicht. Das kann ich nicht. Leute, ich fürchte, ich muss das selbst machen. Datafield.
Weil, wisst ihr, ich glaube, dieser Button, das ist nichts, was die eigentlich in ein Datafield rendern wollen. Ich meine, das ist, keine Ahnung. Ich blick's nicht so ganz. Es ist ja nur ein Datafield. Es scheint ja kein Button zu unterstützen.
Wenn ein Datafield kein Button unterstützt, dann kann man auch kein Button malen. Dementsprechend muss ich selbst anhand der Region, wo geklickt wird, entscheiden. Run without debugging. Was? Wie? Was ist jetzt schon wieder? Der Simulator ist doch da.
Geht doch. Also, wie gesagt, das will ich heute nicht machen. Man kann anhand der Region natürlich schon erkennen, was es für ein Feld ist, was ich geklickt habe. Da muss ich mir nämlich hier merken, wo das Ganze anfängt und wo das aufhört.
Das mache ich ja. Irgendwo male ich doch hier die Striche. Hier, guckt. Sell with. Und nachdem mein Datafield nur darauf ausgelegt ist, einzeilig zu sein, muss ich eigentlich auch nur die x-Koordinaten checken.
Ja, sonst crasht es. Man könnte auch einfach Minus Minus schreiben oder so. Anhand der ersten Koordinaten weiß ich ja, wo ich reingeklickt habe, weil die Weißbreite durch drei.
Lass uns mal das ausprobieren irgendwie. Function mal in. Mir fällt noch gar kein Name dafür in Field oder so.
Und dann Koordinates. Wie übergibt man Koordinates? Moment, wo kriege ich überhaupt die Koordinaten her?
Achso, das kann ich ja dann gar nicht aufrufen. Das ist natürlich nicht so nice jetzt, aber das muss nicht nice sein, das muss nur funktionieren.
Wir simulieren das jetzt mal. Es geht von 1 bis 245. Wir kriegen das raus.
Also, wie war das? War? War start gleich 1. Und jetzt können wir im Prinzip gucken. Ich kriege nicht die Weißbreite, ich kriege den Device Context übergeben als Parameter.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich den selbst anlege. Deswegen hardcoden wir das jetzt grad mal testweise. Magic Numbers, genau.
Warum geht das hier nicht weg? Jetzt können wir nämlich gucken. Wir haben ja im Prinzip nur drei.
Und dann ist das ein Click-Event, was ein Lang-Array-Number bekommt.
Was? Ich will das copy-pasten. Ein Lang-Array-Number. Okay, nice. Alles klar, jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid.
Und was mich interessiert ist, ist das X. X weiß jeder sofort Bescheid.
Koordinates, 0. If, Start, Größer. Na, Größer 1 ist eigentlich klar. Das hier ist doch eigentlich die Breite, im Prinzip.
Das ist im Prinzip die Device-Breite. Das reicht eigentlich.
Also, wenn... Okay, Start, Größer 1 sollte eigentlich klar sein.
Und... Width ist schon okay.
Und noch Cell-Width. Meine Güte, das wird...
Device. Das ist richtig pp-iger.
So, die Zellenbreite, es ist größer als 1.
Und es ist...
Nein. Jetzt ergibt es auch Sinn.
So, und es ist kleiner. Und X ist kleiner.
Die Zellenbreite. Also, machen wir es mal zum Verständnis mal 1.
Dann ist das... Okay, System, Print-Line.
Erstes Feld. If.
Else, if.
Mal 2. Okay, den Start kann ich mir doch eigentlich...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
So, oder?
Das kann man bestimmt deutlich einfacher schreiben.
Ergibt das Sinn, was ich hier mache? 0.
Ja.
Man könnte das vielleicht noch in eine Schleife packen.
So, und das ist 3.
Das funktioniert im Leben doch nicht, was ich hier gebaut habe.
Error-Compile, okay.
Cannot-Resolve-Type-Language-Array.
Top.
Lang.
Error.
Nice.
Moment, warum ist es mal Using und mal ist es Import?
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln?
Ist das ein Alias, das eine auf das andere?
Okay.
Cannot-Find.
Kann man, kann man...
Okay, kann man nicht einfach sagen Number?
Number-Array? Vielleicht geht man das so an.
Äh.
Oh, shit.
Monkey-See-Data-Types.
Language-Reference.
Jetzt. Array.
Ja, ist ja schön und gut, aber wie ist die Syntax dafür?
Ach, es ist Toybox-Lang?
Ey, Funst. Nice.
Okay.
Reload.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das klappt.
Das crasht bestimmt gleich, wenn ich draufklicke.
Ah, ich bin ja auch Hyper-PP-Ger.
Ich rufe das ja nirgendwo auf.
Error.
Was?
Okay, wisst ihr was? Kann man das einfach dynamisch machen, ohne was?
Oder muss man da was hinschreiben?
Ach so, ich, ah, ich hab...
Build-Successfully, okay.
Pork, Pork.
Reload.
Oh, man.
Jetzt.
So, anscheinend nicht.
Na gut.
Dann lass uns mal hier X ausgeben,
ob da was Sinnvolles rauskommt.
Ja, Moment.
Äh.
Start ist, Moment.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Moment. Warte mal. Hä?
Das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn, was ich da gemacht hab.
Das muss sein X
größer
Start, das ergibt ja gar keinen...
gar keinen Sinn, so.
X größer
Start plus
Cell Width
mal 1.
Weil eigentlich
kann ich mir das doch mit dem Start komplett sparen.
Nee.
Warte mal. Hier muss es einfach nur
größer 1 sein, ja?
Eigentlich muss es sogar größer 0 sein.
Nein, es muss
größer, okay.
Größer gleich 1, ja? Okay.
So.
Größer gleich Start muss es sein.
So, da sind wir uns einig.
So, als nächstes
muss es größer
gleich
Start plus
Ähm.
Kann ich doch eigentlich
weglassen. Das ist doch eigentlich komplett unsinnig.
Größer
Größer Cell Width
mal
1, genau.
Aber kleiner
als 2.
Und das letzte
muss X
größer 2.
Okay, ich glaube, so ergibt das mehr Sinn.
Wow!
Darf das? Darf das? Kein Größer?
Ach.
Ich hätte es so schreiben müssen.
Hat funktioniert.
So.
Aha!
Es funzt. Guck mal.
Und es
es funzt auch recht genau.
Okay, gut.
Gut. So, jetzt kriegen wir raus,
welches Feld geklickt wurde.
Das ist doch schon mal nice.
Jetzt ist die große Preisfrage nur.
Ehrlich gesagt
eigentlich größer 0 und das ist es
auf jeden Fall.
Deswegen kann ich es theoretisch
eigentlich kann ich es komplett
weglassen.
Zeile 16.
Einfach nur kleiner Cell Width minus 1.
Das reicht eigentlich schon. Fängt am linken ran dann.
So, jetzt ist natürlich
die Frage, wie kriege
ich diese Info rüber
in das
in die andere Klasse.
Warum ist das
undefined behavior? Ist doch nicht undefined.
Es ist kleiner
als
Breite mal 1. Das heißt, es ist
links im ersten Zelt.
Im ersten Feld.
Zelt, Alter.
Keck Camping.
Ja, du hast recht.
Im Prinzip reicht das hier auch.
Und das könnte man theoretisch
Theoretisch braucht man das
doch nicht mal mit einem If.
Könnte man da nicht am Ende noch irgendwie Modulu
3 oder irgendwas machen?
Ach was. Lassen wir.
Lassen wir. Alles gut.
Was ich mich viel eher frage ist,
hier kriege ich jetzt raus,
wo ich reingeklickt habe.
Schön und gut.
Aber wie kriege ich die Information hier rein?
Weil, sagen wir mal, ich klicke
jetzt auf den Timer.
Dann müsste ich jetzt ja
das ändern von der Time
zu
zu, sagen wir mal,
Ankunftszeit.
Ich bräuchte so eine Art
Global Variable.
Wie macht man das?
Global.
Oder können wir nicht einfach
eine Klasse machen?
Können wir nicht einfach sagen,
irgendwie, Class.
Keine Ahnung.
State.
Machen wir mal.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das schon belegt ist.
Jetzt machen wir Class.
Class.
Da gibt es aber doch bestimmt was
Fertiges.
MyState.
Und jetzt bräuchten wir sowas wie ein
Property oder eine Public
Variable oder sowas in der Richtung.
MonkeySee.
Global Variable.
Object, Modules,
Class, Circle, Function.
Was ist das?
Achso, das ist einfach nur ein Beispiel.
Static.
Glaube ich nicht.
Wäre aber nice.
Hier, Public.
Im Prinzip
brauchen wir sowas.
Public var.
Moment, ich muss da
kein Datatyp angeben.
Okay, machen wir mal.
Sind wir mal nett.
Machen wir hier, Public.
Public var ist jetzt mal A.
Okay.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie kriege ich den State
geshared?
Den State kriege ich doch wahrscheinlich
einfach. Ich kann das doch einfach hier in
Constructor injecten.
Also sagen wir mal hier.
Var. My.
State.
Das muss ich erstmal importieren wahrscheinlich noch.
Import. My.
Ne.
Kann ich einfach so sagen.
Bestimmt
nicht. Das geht bestimmt nicht.
Doch.
Okay.
State soll da rein
und da rein.
Ich hoffe das funktioniert so.
Das ist bestimmt nicht im Sinne
des Erfinders, was ich hier gerade baue.
Phifat. Phifat.
Phifat View.
Moment, ein View
kann wahrscheinlich im Constructor.
Der hat gar keinen Constructor. Doch.
Hat er. Guck mal.
Hier, Blob.
Oder hier.
State.
Ich hoffe das geht so.
State und jetzt das da.
Das hat nicht Initialize.
Aber das können wir
anlegen, dass es ein Initialize hat.
Okay.
Initialize.
So.
Das crashed beim
Kompilieren jetzt. Ne.
Es geht.
Wait a minute. Geht es wirklich
jetzt? Einfach so.
Es gibt Static. Echt.
Static. Wo hast du das
gefunden?
Static.
Aber gibt es auch
Static? Gibt es Variablen?
Das wäre sowas wie
Global.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Public.
Static.
Kackel. Ja.
Dann ist ja noch viel einfacher.
Dann können wir uns diesen ganzen Müll hier sparen.
Sagen Public. Static.
Und dann.
Ja ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es noch nicht genau.
Ich weiß noch nicht genau
wie ich es nenne. Dann schenken
wir uns das ganze Initialize Gedöns.
Ich kann kein Button verwenden.
Weil ein Button
nicht supported ist in einem
Datafield Projekt.
Sagt zumindest das Ding beim Kompilieren.
So dann können wir
das hier auch wieder rausschmeißen.
Ja wunderbar.
Und hier
im
hier auch.
Kompiliert es noch.
Ah ja gut.
Perfekt.
Und das heißt wir setzen das jetzt einfach mal.
Hier.
My State.
Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen kann man nicht
auf Statics zugreifen.
Eigentlich müsste es ja
Blub sein.
Lul.
Ok. Funktioniert.
Funktioniert gut.
Eins. Eins. Zwei.
Ja. Ok.
Immerhin.
Immerhin. Das scheint zu funktionieren.
Ok. Und dann gehen wir jetzt.
Wir sind mal so frei.
Und
debuggen mit dem
Print Output davon.
Und sagen jetzt hier.
My State.
Blub.
So ich kann ihm doch bestimmt ein Default
noch geben.
Default. Default ist
Lulw.
Hat gebildet.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert.
Da sollte jetzt Lulw drinne stehen gleich.
Lulw. Ok. Jetzt klicken wir drauf.
Wir klicken drauf und da sollte jetzt
eins stehen gleich.
Ja so. So halb.
So halb
Funktioniert es anscheinend.
Beim nächsten
Draw
funktioniert es dann. Ok.
Ah ja gut.
Das ergibt Sinn. Ich mal es immer im gleichen Feld.
Gut. Also von
der Idee her
funktioniert es mit dem State.
Mit dem State.
Ja.
Mir gefällt der Ansatz
nicht wirklich.
Aber vielleicht reicht das.
Wir haben den SDK State.
Vielleicht haben die aber auch
irgendwas
höher. Ja irgendwie.
Vielleicht haben die irgendein State Management
eingebaut. Ja.
Ja mir fällt
nichts anderes ein was ähnlich
easy ist.
Globale Variable reicht ja für sowas.
So jetzt müssen wir uns eigentlich merken.
Ich weiß.
Ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher was ich
eigentlich bauen will gerade.
Verwirrt hat mich das ganze jetzt.
Also ich mein ich wollte doch.
Wenn man ein Feld
anklickt.
Ja ne das ist scheiße.
Ich brauche keinen. Ich brauche
nicht diesen globalen State. Ich brauche eigentlich
ein Event. Eigentlich brauche ich
ein Event. Ich brauche ein Event.
Feld 1 klickt. Feld 2
klickt. Feld 3 klickt.
Ich brauche eine Art Event.
Callback.
Observer oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
Einen Callback.
Und
den rufe ich
auf. Und dann
kann ich drauf reagieren dass dieses Feld umkommt.
Weil so ist das ja mega abartig.
Noah loves pancakes.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Weil so ist das ja mega abartig. Wenn ich jetzt klicke.
Dann dauert es bis zum nächsten
Refresh. Wie ihr seht der auch mal
5 Sekunden oder so dauern kann. Hier.
Da klick. Guckt.
3 kommt jetzt gleich rein. Das dauert
eine Sekunde oder so nach dem klicken.
Guckt ungefähr eine Sekunde bis zum
nächsten Refresh. Je nachdem wann die
Loop da läuft.
Und dann refresht er das.
Es gibt keinen Button.
Den ich verwenden kann.
Ein Datafield ist das Ding.
Was man hier benutzt zum Anzeigen.
Eigentlich ist das hier ein Datafield.
In das ich 3 kleine Datafields male.
Weil Garmin
nur an der Stelle
ein Datafield anzeigen lassen kann. Aber ich will 3.
Ein Event Bus.
Jetzt wird es.
Jetzt wird es advanced. Ja sowas.
So was bräuchte ich.
Das haben die bestimmt
sowas drin. Events.
Callback oder so.
Das gibt es bestimmt.
Hier. Input Handling.
Ja genau.
Das kenne ich. Nur dass ich
von meiner State Klasse
eigentlich in die andere.
Ja wie gesagt. Ich kann keinen Button verwenden.
Das bringt nichts.
Wenn ich Buttons verwenden könnte.
Wäre das easy. Dann müsste ich das nicht
selbst bauen. Gibt es da Generics?
Ne.
Du kannst es aber dynamisch machen. Du musst gar keinen Typ angeben.
Ich muss mir das
Beispiel auch mal angucken von dem Typ.
Garmin.
GitHub. Der Typ hatte doch irgendwie
Input.
Er hatte auch ein Beispiel hier.
Oh man ist das ein
Krampf man.
Delegate.
Setzt der da vielleicht irgendwas?
Initialize.
Hier. War
last key button
pressed?
Sollte ich vielleicht auch sowas machen?
Ich meine gehen.
Mit einem Event wäre das auf jeden Fall
deutlich sinnvoller.
Gehen wird.
Set Status
String. Wo kommt denn das her?
String.
Wo kommt denn das her?
Nicht von hier.
Äh. Alter.
What?
Bin ich jetzt gelandet?
Alter manchmal ist der Browser auch echt
krass ppga.
Hier Function.
Moment. Moment. Moment. Moment.
Moment. Moment.
Moment. Man kann.
Jetzt pläge ich den mal durch.
So kann man das
austauschen dazwischen?
Ja aber das ist immer noch kein Event.
Aber hier haben wir Request Update.
Hey das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Oh man das ist
gar nicht das
Watch UI Request Update.
Moment das probieren wir jetzt mal.
Dann sollte es
dann sollte es eigentlich Instant. Instant
funktionieren. Watch UI
Request Update.
Build Project.
Ah. Successful.
Äh.
Ähm. Was soll ich damit?
Das ist Java.
Hä? Event Bus?
Was soll ich damit?
Ich brauch kein Java.
Ich brauch Monkey Sea.
Ja sowas bauen kann ich auch.
Das krieg ich schon.
Sowas krieg ich schon hingewurschtelt.
Aber nicht unbedingt in Monkey Sea.
Du hast schon recht.
Wir könnten sowas selbst bauen.
Wir könnten uns irgendwie eine Klasse
ob Server oder so bauen.
Das muss ich mal in Ruhe
durchdenken.
Oh ist es jetzt crashed?
Nee.
Watch UI Request Update funktioniert nicht mehr.
Wir haben es kaputt gemacht.
Request Update.
Nee Moment. Wir haben es nicht
kaputt gemacht. Stimmt doch nicht das wir es kaputt gemacht haben.
Es
steht hier einfach
wieder Hardcoded drinnen.
Was ist Monkey Sea?
Das ist irgendeine Garmin
eigene Sprache.
Nur für diese Dinger.
Nein das ist kein Java.
Also Java ist
zwar eklig aber so eklig auch nicht.
Aber ich find es von der Syntax her gar nicht so eklig.
Guck mal.
Jetzt geht es doch.
Guck mal jetzt geht es doch halbwegs schnell oder?
Ich meine Event
wäre trotzdem noch nicer.
Aber jetzt geht es doch voll klar von der Geschwindigkeit her.
Jetzt geht es doch
eigentlich halbwegs klar.
Okay dann müssen wir das anders nennen.
Dann muss das.
Das muss halt
so ein bisschen Event Charakter haben.
Das blöde ist.
Wir können das zum Beispiel nennen.
Field
Tapped oder so.
Schreibt man das überhaupt
so.
Ich schreibe standardmäßig 0 rein.
So Field Tapped.
Das könnten wir so nennen.
Dann steht da jetzt 3 drinnen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass ich kein Handle
State habe.
Ich meine ich muss ja wissen
dass der Tap
gehandelt wurde.
Sonst würde der jedes Mal das wieder machen.
Also zum Beispiel.
Ich drücke jetzt da drauf.
Er setzt Field Tapped
auf 2.
Beim nächsten Redraw ändert er die Zahl
hier drin auf das was nach einem Tap passieren soll.
Dann müsste ich Field Tapped
danach wieder auf 0 stellen.
Weil ich ja
das nächste Mal beim nächsten Redraw
sonst wieder denken würde es ist getappt.
Also ich muss das komplett manuell
machen.
Das finde ich richtig eklig.
Die Frage ist wie teuer die Funktion ist.
Das juckt mich nicht an der Stelle.
Also es müsste.
Ich kann keine
Buttons und Selectables malen, weil das in einem
Data Field Objekt nicht
erlaubt ist.
Also ich müsste jetzt
hier quasi gucken.
If
Das können wir ja mal einbauen.
If myState
Jetzt habe ich das
Oh man das ist so
abartig. Kann man diesen Kack hier mal wegschieben.
Field Tapped
Ungleich
Ungleich 0
Wenn es gleich 0 ist
Nee
Wenn es ungleich 0 ist
So muss ich das machen.
dann will ich es wieder
auf 0
Nee will ich gar nicht.
Moment viel zu kompliziert.
Wenn ich durch bin mit malen
dann wird das einfach immer
auf 0 gesetzt. So fertig.
Und hier kann ich jetzt
gucken. If
Ja sagen wir mal
sagen wir jetzt mal
If myState
Field Tapped
ist 1
Warum auch immer das ein String sein muss, fragt mich bitte nicht.
Beste Variante
das als String zu machen.
Was da steht? Statics?
Wo?
Ach hier.
Ja
Nicht wirklich.
Und jetzt könnte ich sagen
Values
Das 1 ist 0
Setzen wir jetzt auf
Moment hat er gerade Auto formatiert?
Irgendwie versucht?
Values
Nee der hat
Zeug gemacht.
Values ist jetzt
Guck mal hier, dass wir es verstehen
Das ist
Time. Wir machen mal T dahinter.
Dass man es irgendwie
unterscheiden kann.
Und das nach einem Klick
ist
Ich muss mir auch den letzten
State davon auch merken.
Und das andere ist
bis wir arriven.
Oder so.
Bild
Ah ja.
Weil ich das falsch genannt habe.
Field Tapped
Okay. Successful. Reload.
Du könntest auch eine
Public Function machen. GetEntrySet
Das finde ich ist
keine schlechte Idee.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Okay.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass es funktioniert.
Ist wieder Hardcore. Wieso? Was denn?
Nee nee es sollte sich
ändern.
Nee.
Muss ich vielleicht
vorher noch so eine Art Clear oder so machen.
Dass es einmal weg ist.
Jetzt verstehe ich
es nicht so ganz. Warum das
nicht funktioniert.
Okay. System.
Printline.
Gutes
Printline Debugging.
Ich kann. Wie oft soll ich das denn noch
sagen?
In einem Datafield Projekt
sind keine Selectables
oder zumindest keine Buttons erlaubt.
Wenn du weißt wie es geht, dann erzähl.
Aber das
sagt eindeutig der Compiler, wenn ich es
ausprobiere. Und ansonsten
ist das nächste. Ich weiß ja noch nicht mal
wie ich das überhaupt malen soll.
Ich müsste auf jeden Fall
von Hand malen. So mit Breite und
Höhe. Weil Layouts kann ich auch nicht
verwenden. Das funktioniert nicht.
Leute.
Warum funktioniert das nicht?
Field tapped sollte
auf 1 gestellt werden. Wird das aber nicht.
Was ist das
für ein Kack?
My state. Field tapped.
Warum steht das auf...
Was ist da los?
Warum geht das nicht?
Was ist da?
Warum buggt das jetzt?
Es ist doch 1.
Moment. Und da ist es 0?
What?
Nee doch. Es ist doch 1.
Und danach wird es wieder auf 0 gesetzt.
Ähm.
Chatge. Ich habe absolut keinen
Plan, warum der nicht in dieses
If reingeht. Hier.
Lass doch mal kurz.
Der ist weg. Hat das
irgendwie Multithreading Probleme?
Oder sowas vielleicht?
Aber das ist ja nicht mal großartig.
Da wird... Das ist doch...
Das ist egal. Das hat noch nicht mal Multithreading.
Kann auch nicht mal Multithreading Probleme haben.
Es ist die ganze Zeit
1, aber...
Es ist offensichtlich 1.
Aber das If...
Hä?
Vielleicht geht ein String
compare anders.
Ja. Das könnte
noch sein.
Wir machen das anders. Wir benutzen einfach
mal ins.
Wir benutzen einfach mal ins.
Warum sollten wir überhaupt?
1. Okay.
Jetzt
funktioniert's.
Okay. Jetzt geht's.
Alles klar.
Das ist einfach nur PPGA String Vergleich.
Wir sind ja nicht bei Javascript.
Ey, ich glaube sogar in C kannst du das so
schreiben.
Und alles was in C ist,
sollte so Baseline
sein. Also ich gebe zu,
dass das extrem eklig ist.
Aber... Ey!
Achso, Moment. Das überschreibt
einfach das nächste Mal wieder.
Ja, ja. Ach ja.
Ja, logisch. Jetzt verstehe ich, warum
es nicht funktioniert. Der überschreibt das
das nächste Mal einfach wieder.
Der rendert einmal kurz das rein mit A
und dann überschreibt das ja wieder.
Weil das hier nicht gesetzt... Gut.
Das heißt, ich brauche für jedes Datafield
ein current state,
der geupdated wird.
Also im Prinzip sowas hier
wie... Tja.
Hinten war
MyValueM, was auch immer. Ich brauche
irgendwie... War... Keine Ahnung.
Ähm.
Och, das ist so eklig, Mann.
Das ist so abartig.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich das so lassen will.
Warum benutze ich... Warum steht
hier überhaupt M-Value drin?
Was mache ich hier mit M-Value?
Brauche ich M-Value überhaupt für irgendwas?
M-Value.
M-Value hat überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das ist noch vom Example-Code übrig.
Also ich brauche im Prinzip sowas wie...
Nennen wir es einfach...
Field1.
Ähm.
Keine Ahnung.
Field1.
Mir fällt noch nicht mal ein Name dafür ein, Mann.
Field1State.
Okay? Oh. False.
Ja.
Das ist richtig abartig, Mann.
So.
Und jetzt muss ich gucken,
wenn Field1 tapped ist,
dann setzen wir
das hier mal auf true.
Leute, es muss jetzt für ein
Field mal funktionieren, okay?
So.
Und hier im...
Das Value
wird gesetzt entweder
wenn...
Wenn das so ist oder
so.
Okay.
Hoffentlich geht das, ja.
Ja, ja. Nice, nice.
Aha.
Äh.
Und das muss not sein.
Ey, das ist so ultra
abfuck, Mann.
Eigentlich, Leute,
wäre es auch sinnvoll,
mehrere States zu erlauben, ja?
Dass man beispielsweise haben könnte
Timer,
Zeit zur Ankunft
und irgendwie noch was Drittes
oder so.
Aber das hier wird jetzt funktionieren.
So, Klick. Es ist A. Noch ein Klick.
Es ist wieder T. Noch ein Klick.
Es ist immer noch A.
Ah, nee. Es ist einfach nur langsam.
Okay, das ist natürlich auch in Ordnung.
Oh, A.
Okay, guck. Man kann switchen zwischen den Feldern.
Nice.
Wir haben nur zwei Stunden dafür gebraucht,
dass wir in den Feld switchen können.
Was passiert, wenn man wie verrückt da klickt?
Also ich muss
auf jeden Fall mal gucken,
wie man da
irgendwelche Events
draus machen kann.
Aber ihr seht, es ist schon halbwegs schnell.
Ich zeige euch das hier mal.
Klick.
Also es ist
halbwegs
schnell. Ihr hört es ja gerade.
Es hat so eine halbe Sekunde
Verzögerung.
Also das geht halbwegs.
Aber schön
ist es beim besten Willen
so, nicht?
Also vielleicht
machen wir wirklich hier so eine...
Nee, der Fahrradcomputer ist sonst
nicht sonderlich snappy. Das stimmt schon.
Vielleicht sollten wir sogar einfach nur
hier public
sowas machen wie hier
ja
public static
field one
state
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal false da rein.
So und jetzt
machen wir sowas wie hier function
function
field one
tapped
irgendwie so
und hier in diesem
delegate
sagen wir dann bloß
Moment, ist das public?
Oh nee.
Sekunde.
Das muss bestimmt auch static
sein.
Static function
public
public static function
vielleicht?
Und jetzt brauchen wir
sowas wie field one
tapped
Geht das jetzt?
Moment.
Was?
Ah.
Mal wieder. Mal wieder ein Semikolon.
Es hat
gebildet, Leute. Es hat gebildet.
Ah ja, Moment. Das wird jetzt noch nicht
funktionieren.
Das wird jetzt nicht funktionieren. Wir können allerdings
an der Stelle hier sagen, wir können uns
das ganze State Management hier
drinnen sparen.
Das ganze State Management hier drinnen sparen.
Und da können wir es uns
drinnen sparen und im Prinzip
sagen
If
Nee, wie heißt das?
Field stay.
If das, dann das. So.
So. Das müsste jetzt
gehen.
Bild.
Das ist schon mal ein bisschen angenehmer
jetzt. Nicht mal ganz so
abartig. Ja.
Funzt.
Okay, das ist schon mal nicht mehr ganz so doof.
Nächster Streamtitel.
Das ist
ein guter Streamtitel, ja.
Den mache ich mal für morgen schon rein.
Falls wir morgen weitermachen.
Written in Rust.
Guter Streamtitel.
Das ist der nächste
Streamtitel für morgen dann.
Multiparadigm
Monkeysy
Placingly Fast Garment Implementation.
Leute, das finde ich
jetzt schon mal gar nicht mehr ganz so
schlimm, wie es jetzt ist.
Ja, da können wir
uns das hier...
Das finde ich schon mal
irgendwie halbwegs machbar jetzt.
Wisst ihr, was noch viel
besser wäre, wenn es sowas wie
Properties gäbe?
Das überlege
ich mir mal. Mit nem Event wäre das
immer noch viel viel angenehmer.
Aber ich meine, das geht
jetzt schon halbwegs. Das geht jetzt.
Das kann jetzt nämlich raus.
Und jetzt brauchen wir theoretisch
Field 1 stay, Field 2
Stay, Field 3 Stay.
1... Es ist immer noch
eklig. Ja?
Es ist immer noch eklig.
Oder wir machen...
Oder wir sagen hier
tapped.
Und hier geben wir ne Nummer an.
I
Und das hier
wird ein
Array.
Äh.
Ne.
Ne, kein Array. Plötzlich.
Ähm.
Nen Bool Dictionary
mit
mit Index
als Key.
Okay, wie macht man
nen Dictionary? So?
1.
Monkey C
Dictionary.
Hashtable, wie auch immer man das nennen mag.
Aha.
Okay.
So was hier.
Okay, also wir wollen 1.
Wie war das? Ein Pfeil, ne?
1.
False. 2.
False.
3.
Ich muss ins Bett gleich.
3 False. Jetzt sagen wir tapped. I.
Field State.
I.
Gleich. Not
Field State. I.
Fuck, ob das funktioniert?
Okay.
Ganz, ganz teuer.
Wir lassen das jetzt mal raus.
Wir machen nur das 1er.
Tapped. Ne.
Tapped.
I. Okay.
Jetzt gehen wir hier zurück und sagen
Field State.
I.
Und ist das so? Fuck.
Mismatch. Oh, hab ich
n Semikolon wieder ver... Ne.
Äh.
Das ist
Monkeysy. Mismatched Input.
Expecting.
Ach hier.
Ich vergesse immer diese Semikolonzahl.
Monkeysy.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Garmin Ding.
Das ist mir egal, ob er das erkennt oder nicht.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das am Ende Java ist.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass die
Implementierung irgendwie in Java ist, aber auf dem
Gerät selbst wird nicht Java sein.
Okay, Leute. Es funktioniert.
Problem
solved.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Sag mal, wie oft... Chat gibt.
Wie oft soll ich es ja noch sagen, dass
wenn ich ein Button verwende, das Ding sagt,
dass in diesem Applikationstype
es nicht erlaubt ist, ein Button zu
benutzen.
Und ich bezweifle auch,
dass es erlaubt ist,
Custom Buttons zu machen dann.
Zumal
ich mir einen eigenen Button dann bauen müsste,
den ich dann wiederum
draw.
Du meinst, Selectable ist erlaubt, aber kein Button?
Das glaube ich nicht,
weil Button erbt von Selectable.
Ich vermute mal, wenn Button nicht geht,
bin ich sehr wundert, wenn Selectable geht.
Mal ganz einfach abgesehen,
ob ich den Selectable
selbst
draw oder das, so einen großen
Unterschied ist es nicht.
Außer, dass ich wahrscheinlich
ein Klick-Event kriegen würde.
Ich meine, wir haben es ja jetzt gelöst.
Funktioniert doch.
Es ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Ich meine, wir können das setzen.
Wir wissen, welches Feld aktiv ist.
Und dann können wir darauf reagieren.
Das ist gar nicht übel.
Ich glaube, das kann man so lassen.
Vielleicht fällt mir noch ein bisschen was Schöneres ein.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen
finde ich das
noch so schlimm. Ich finde das durchaus
gangbarer Weg hier.
Ich meine, das gefällt mir noch nicht so richtig.
Sonstherr
ist das schon okay.
Aber ich muss pennen, Leute.
Bettge-Time.
Bettge.
Ich glaube, alle Variablen sind immer nicht schön.
Aber, muss man auch mal sagen,
bei so
Microcontroller-Embedded-Kram
auch nicht unbedingt so selten.
Monkey sees
an Argument, kein Garmin zu kaufen.
Warum? Bei den anderen kannst du einfach
gar nichts machen. Ist doch gut, dass du
sowas bauen kannst.
Ja, da werden wir uns dann die Tage
Gedanken drüber machen. Aber jetzt muss ich erst mal pennen.
Bettge-Time.
Ich sehe,
die Hälfte von euch sind auch schon pennen.
Weil Punkt 22 Uhr sind irgendwie
40 Viewer oder so raus. Instant.
Alle weg.
Da stehe ich aber. Viele Leute müssen um die gleiche Uhrzeit ins Bett.
Ungefähr zumindest.
Weil morgen nochmal schaffen.
Wir sehen uns, Leute.
Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.